One of the most common design patterns for multithreaded applications is
the producer consumer model. This can be viewed as a special case
of one of the models discussed before, if you like. To
motivate our discussion, we'll use a
tracking application. Here's our camera. Maybe
it's monitoring the number of people on a subway platform to
help route trains, or something like that. You can then break the
computation down into two pieces. One, is to get the picture
from the camera into the memory. We'll call this the producer task.
And the other task, is to analyze the picture to figure
out where all the people are, and pass this information on to
the training planner, or whoever may need it. We'll call this, the
consumer task. Now for this scenario, suppose the images are available from
the camera every 33 milliseconds. We want to get all of them,
so we're going to have a thread whose job is just to copy
the frame from the camera, into computer memory. And let's say that
the image processing to find the people is variable, taking somewhere between
20 and 40 milliseconds. But on average, less than 33. If
it were more than 33, we could put more consumer threads here
to do the work. Because of the variability in the time
it takes to process the image, we need a place in which
to store images that our consumer thread is not yet ready
to handle. And for this, we use a ring buffer. Each division
here represents memory for our frame from the camera. The ones that
haven't been consumed yet, I've colored in red. Now we should imagine
the producer and consumer threads chasing each other around this ring,
with the producer one writing frames, making them red, and the consumer
one running behind, turning them back to white. That is, empty
or processed. Though of course the consumer will never pass the producer.